في تطورات الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اعلنت الصحه الفلسطيني عن مقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في نابلس في الضفه الغربيه بعد
اشتباكات مع القوات الاسرائيليه وقال
المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني
احمد جبريل لان القوات تمنع الطواقيم
الطبيه بل ان القوات الاسرائيليه تمنع
الطواقم الطبيه والاسعاف من الاصول
للمصابين حيث بدات الاشتباكاته بعدما كشف
شهود عيان وجود قوه اسرائيليه بزين مدني
فلسطيني لتقتحم بعد ذلك عشرات الاليه
العسكريه المنطقه
من نابلس مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل ما
زال التوتر سيد الموقف في نابلسم الذي
انتهت اليه الاوضاع حتى اللحظه
يعني انتهت الاوضاع بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
قتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين قالت البيان العسكري
الاسرائيلي بان اثنين من الثلاثه كان
ضالعان في عمليه عمليه اطلاق نار في
الاغوار بدايه الشهر الماضي
ادت الى مقتل ثلاثه
مستوطنات
القتيل الثالث هو صاحب المنزل الذي تحصن
به عدد من المسلحين وحاصرته قوات خاصه
اسرائيليه
وقوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح
اليوم في حي الياسمينه في البلده القديمه
من مدينه نابلس نحن هنا امام مستشفى
رفيديا بانتظار
ان تخرج جنازات من قتلهم الجيش الاسرائيلي
من هنا من داخل المشفى وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه اضافه عن اعلانها عن مقتل
ثلاثه فلسطينيين قالت بان اكثر من 160
اصابه
غالبيتها كانت من اصابات بالاختناق جراء
استنشاق الغاز المسيل للدموع داخل مدرسه
محاذيه للمنزل الذي حاصرته القوات
الاسرائيليه صباح هذا اليوم قبل قليل
انسحب الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه بشكل كامل من داخل
البلده القديمه في نابلس ومن محيط البلده
القديمه لكنه تمركز على الحواجز العسكريه
الاسرائيليه المحيط او المنتشره في محيط
مدينه نابلس يمنع بعض الحواجز استمنع
الدخول الى نابلس وبعض الحواجز تمنع
الخروج ولكن جميع الحوادث تدفق
ين الذين يعبرون هذه الحواجز باتجاه مناطق
الضفه الغربيه المختلفه يعني خالد هذه
الاشتباكات بدات بعد ما كشف شهود عيان
وجود قوه اسرائيليه مدني فلسطيني هل هذا
هو هذا ما حدث تحديدا يعني هي كانت منذ
صبيحه هذا اليوم متواجده في هذه المنطقه
ربما للاستكشاف ما الذي تحدث
نعم اختار القوات الاسرائيليه توقيت
ذهاب الموظفين الى اعمالهم وايضا
ذهاب الطلبه الى مدارسهم عندها تكون ذروه
الحركه في مدينه نابلس وتحديدا في البلده
القديمه المغلقه
والمسكوفه
اختارت هذا التوقيت وتسلل مجموعه من
القوات الخاصه التابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي
بزي مدني فلسطيني رجال ونساء ولكن
لتكرار هذه الاعمال سواء في نابلس او جنين
شك الفلسطينيون بالموضوع وتنبهوا والقوه
من المنزل الذي فيه
بحسب شهود العيان كان يتواجد فيه ثمانيه
مسلحين فلسطينيين دارت اشتباكات بعد ان
تحصنت القوات الخاصه في منزل مجاور وهرعت
قوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي من جميع
مداخل مدينه نابلس
بمحاصره والدخول الى البلده القديمه اضافه
الى مرافقه مسيرات فوق البلده القديمه قال
شهود العيان بانها اطلقت قنابل غازيه
وقنابل صوتيه وبعضهم قال بان
مطلقه باتجاه المنزل الذي تحصن فيه
المسلحون ما ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه واصابه
عدد اخر بشظايا هذه الخلائق لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات